plusieurs politiciens qui parlent de ce
qui se passe au chemin Roxane nous on va
vous montrer ce qui arrive avant la
frontière le lucratif marché des
passages qui exploite la détresse de
ceux qui sont prêts à tout pour refaire
leur vie au Canada
[Musique]
là on est derrière l'une des
camionnettes qui va aller jusqu'à Roxane
Road les camionnettes comme celle-là se
sont multipliées sur les routes des
États-Unis direction nord ça explique
peut-être pourquoi il y a jamais eu
autant de migrants qui passent par le
chemin Roxane qu'en ce moment et on va
vous amener au cœur de cette curieuse
industrie du voyage clandestin
financièrement c'est une grande commerce
une économie du désespoir et un trafic
qui semble complètement toléré par les
autorités américaines les Américains
font nada 0 c'est pas ça sont en train
de faire le boulot des autorités
immigrations américains ici Marie Maud
Denis bienvenue à cette 16e saison dans
le cadre
[Musique]
cette scène s'est produite des dizaines
de milliers de fois depuis 2017
des migrants de partout dans le monde
arrivent ici pour demander l'asile au
Canada
[Musique]
c'est le célèbre chemin rock Sam qui a
ouvert ses portes le toits dernier après
avoir été fermé durant la pandémie
depuis le flow ne s'arrête pas au
contraire le nombre de migrants qui
passent par là ne cesse d'augmenter
j'ai l'impression que c'est vraiment le
bouche à oreille
et Jean peuvent arriver en voiture et
donc ils traversent ils se retrouvent au
Canada
immatriculé en Floride ne sont peut-être
pas étrangères à cette croissance
[Musique]
même les policiers canadiens sont
surpris par cet étrange nouveauté envoie
de plus en plus de camionnette privée à
chaque fois il y a plus de 10 personnes
dedans on n'avait jamais vu ça avant
plusieurs agents fédéraux ont partagé
avec nous de manière confidentielle
leurs inquiétudes
des particuliers conduisent ces
camionnettes et ils ne se font pas
intercepter par les policiers américains
le transport de migrants vers le Canada
est devenu un commerce très lucratif aux
États-Unis et ailleurs dans le monde
bienvenue dans les coulisses du chemin
Roxane
[Musique]
presque tous les jours depuis 5 ans
aussi chaque après-midi est distribue
des vêtements migrants des peluches à
leurs enfants
[Musique]
je pense que je peux donner un bon mot
je peux les rassurer
chez la mairesse de Champlain une ville
rurale de l'État de New York là où est
située le chemin Roxane
[Musique]
cette ancienne prof de français tricote
chaque semaine avec ses amis des gants
et des foulards pour les migrants
et elles sont tristes de les voir
quitter les États-Unis je suis américain
j'ai mon pays mais il y a des problèmes
et
ça ne marche pas pour tout le monde je
comprends qu'il y a des personnes qui ne
peuvent pas vivre ici mais ça m'a rentré
ces dernières années elle a vu des
milliers de personnes entre au Canada
mais aussi l'émergence d'une industrie
de plus en plus professionnelle qu'il
inquiète
un réseau de beaucoup de personnes
différentes et tout le monde profite
financièrement
depuis quelques mois c'est camionnettes
blanches arrivent plusieurs fois par
semaine pleine de migrants ça c'est une
vraie on m'a dit que c'est veines
viennent du sud des États-Unis mais
quand on parle de l'argent
on fait beaucoup de choses pour gagner
de l'argent
ces véhicules immatriculés en Floride
n'étaient pas là avant la pandémie
mais qui conduit ces camionnettes et
comment fonctionne ce commerce
[Musique]
loin des plages et du luxe la Floride
est devenue depuis quelques mois une
plaque tournante de la migration
irrégulière par le Canada c'est d'ici
que partent les camionnettes blanches
le chauffeur il m'a donné un rendez-vous
qui va me venir chez moi à 9h cet
immigrant africain c'est bien comment
fonctionne ce service de camionnette il
a fait affaire avec l'un des nombreux
chauffeurs de Floride ils ont une place
voiture c'est sous forme de vent
ce commerce est en plein essor autour de
Miami le prix du voyage aussi les réé
entre 400 et 700 dollars américains pour
aller jusqu'à Roxane
pour en avoir le cœur net on a tenté
notre chance on a appelé un passeur en
prétextant être un migrant kurde tout
juste arrivé aux États-Unis et qui
souhaite aller au Canada
il faut bien comprendre qu'il y a pas de
service d'immigration à Roxane les
policiers canadiens arrêtent les
migrants puis les transports à l'agent
des services frontaliers personne n'est
accepté comme réfugiés dès son arrivée
l'étude de la demande d'asile peut
ensuite durer des mois voire des années
et la réponse peut être négative
[Musique]
il nous offre donc de nous emmener
jusqu'à Roxane à condition de payer en
liquide plusieurs centaines de dollars
mais est-ce légal pour la police
canadienne la réponse est sans équivoque
des particuliers qui facilitent les
conseils les passages illégal à la
frontière peuvent en effet faire l'objet
d'accusation au Canada
on a repris contact avec le propriétaire
de ces camionnettes blanches cette fois
on s'est présenté comme des journalistes
canadiens il accepte de nous rencontrer
mais il y a une seule condition pas de
caméra il nous donne rendez-vous à une
heure de Miami dans ce bureau
ça a commencé pendant la covid mon
business c'est le
transporter au Canada il trouvait
personne pour les amener
cet homme d'une trentaine d'années à
vous faire parfois plusieurs trajets par
semaine une route qui prend deux jours
et qu'il parcourt sans presque jamais
s'arrêter
je parle vendredi matin on arrive le
samedi soir à Roxane
je dors là-bas et ensuite je reviens
vous avez fait beaucoup de trajet depuis
début de la part de news vous avez
beaucoup d'appels
beaucoup énormément d'appels il y a
beaucoup d'iciens qui veulent aller au
Canada
en une semaine je peux faire facilement
80 personnes tu vois il y a deux gars
qui travaillent pour moi puis maintenant
ils sont partis faire leur business
si 10 personnes payent chacune 500
dollars chaque trajet lui rapporte 5000
dollars et il peut y avoir plusieurs
camionnettes par trajet
[Musique]
les gens ils viennent d'un peu partout
ils viennent du Texas de l'Ohio
Indianapolis
la Louisiane des fois je prends des gens
même à New Jersey
plusieurs véhicules partent chaque
semaine de différentes villes
américaines vers Roxane on est donc face
à une industrie qui peut générer des
millions de dollars par année
en face de nous nous raconte une astuce
pour ne pas être identifiée par la
police canadienne
je veux pas aller jusqu'à Roxane
alors j'arrête à plat une
station-service je rencontre un gars un
blanc de la région je paye 200$ par
trajet il amène les gens jusqu'à Roxane
je l'attends à sa voiture
on lui a proposé de payer notre place
pour partir avec lui mais il a refusé
[Musique]
vendredi matin on s'est donc rendu sur
place à nouveau et on a eu de la chance
les camionnettes se préparer à partir et
on a décidé de les suivre
là on est derrière l'une des
camionnettes qui va aller jusqu'à Roxane
elle est vide pour l'instant on part de
Floride
[Musique]
la route traverse 6 États américains de
la Floride à l'état de New York
[Musique]
après plus de 2500 km les camionnettes
arrivent sans aucun problème au chemin
Roxane
qui nous a mis sur la piste des
camionnettes à acheter sa place dans
l'un de ses véhicules
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'il est si facile
de transporter des migrants jusqu'à
Roxane là où il est pourtant interdit de
traverser la frontière on a posé cette
question à un ancien agent fédéral
américain
quand je travaillais à la frontière on a
demandé au procureur américain la
possibilité d'appliquer une sorte
d'accusation fédérale à ces personnes et
je ne veux
non travailler plus de 20 ans pour la
police des frontières il connaît toutes
ses problématiques
le procureur nous a dit qu'on ne pouvait
pas appliquer notre loi sur le trafic et
ses individus en fait il transporte
quelqu'un d'un point A à un point B dans
le territoire américain et il n'y a rien
dans la loi qui répond exactement à ça
[Musique]
Normand a pris sa retraite juste avant
le début de la pandémie
il a ouvert un café à quelques
kilomètres du chemin Roxane
même s'il se tient à l'écart désormais
du monde policier l'histoire qu'on lui
raconte sur ses camionnettes blanches
réveille en lui son flair d'enquêteur
il y a probablement un certain nombre de
lois qui sont en freinent il faut savoir
s'il déclare l'argent gagné avec ce
transport de personnes et s'ils étaient
autorisés à le faire
comme tant d'autres demandeurs d'asile
Koffi est finalement arrivé à Montréal
ces derniers jours grâce à ses
camionnettes blanches
à samedi et aux environs de 28 ans
[Musique]
après la pause des migrants qui partent
de loin et qui sont prêts à tout
les gens qui n'a pas d'argent
subitement des viols
[Musique]
le rêve américain la terre de liberté de
possibilités ça certainement été vrai
pour des générations de gens dans le
plus grand espoir était d'entrer aux
États-Unis mais ces dernières années nos
voisins du Sud sont beaucoup moins
accueillants ce qui rend le Canada
encore plus attrayant
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la petite Haïti l'oasis
entier de Miami 6 rue coloré ou la
culture haïtienne rayonne font le charme
de ce quartier
[Musique]
les milliers des siens se sont installés
au fil des années en quête d'une vie
meilleure
mais depuis peu les nouveaux arrivants
ne rêvent plus des États-Unis
c'est d'ici que via une bonne partie des
demandeurs d'asile qu'on retrouve au
chemin Roxane
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ne veulent
plus rester aux États-Unis cette
question on n'est pas les seuls à se la
poser
[Musique]
Franz André est un défenseur du droit
des migrants de Montréal
son travail humanitaire lui a déjà valu
une médaille de l'Assemblée nationale du
Québec
tous les jours frant reçoit des dizaines
d'appels ou de messages de migrants
voulant quitter les États-Unis pour
venir au Canada il faut comprendre la
réalité de ces gens qui nous arrivent à
nos frontières avec trop de 26 énorme
Franz a commencé à s'occuper des
demandeurs d'asile en 2017 il est
conscient que maintenant le profil et
les motivations des migrants sont bien
différents
qui a été qui se place pour les gens
justement de la Floride jusque à la
frontière canadienne les gens pour
arriver au Canada entre autres ils sont
prêts à tout faire
prendre sa de nombreux contacts dans le
milieu haïtien il nous emmène visiter un
organisme d'aide au migrants très connu
dans la région très jolie ici
avec lui les portes s'ouvrent plus
facilement et bienvenue au fameux
vous êtes nos invités aujourd'hui donc
Christian and fit est l'un des
responsables de cet organisme qui aide
quotidiennement des familles haïtiennes
au statut précaire il comprend la
volonté de ces personnes de quitter leur
pays la jeunesse bien sûr c'est Haïti où
les gens ont dû quitter leur situation
et souvent pour des raisons de
persécution pour des raisons
d'extrême difficulté mais selon Paul les
choses ont changé aux États-Unis de
nombreux migrants ne s'y sentent plus
les bienvenus
[Musique]
les gens qui arrivent ici c'est très
très difficile c'est famille qui ont été
légalement admises aux États-Unis pour
les autorités fédérales américaines sont
traités ici de criminal et diligo entre
guillemets ne soient pas surpris si les
immigrants y compris haïtiens vont de
plus en plus au Canada je pense ça joue
politiquement d'une façon très
différente et probablement ceci explique
pourquoi vous êtes beaucoup plus
accueillant
[Musique]
avec 30 cendrées on part visiter une
église catholique située au cœur de la
petite Haïti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est la fête du Canada
aussi car Saint-Jean-Baptiste c'est le
ici personne ne s'en cache l'église aide
les migrants peu importe la façon dont
ils sont arrivés aux États-Unis même
ceux qui veulent aller au Canada que la
situation des Haïtiens plus spécialement
des réfugiés
est une situation infra-humaine le
gouvernement américain ne traite pas
vraiment les Haïtiens d'une façon
juste et bien le père et jennel
Jean-Marie est l'une des plus
importantes voies de cette communauté il
accueille à bras ouverts les migrants
qui le sollicitent
pas ici il doit trouver un lieu qui les
accueille
tous les mois l'église organise
plusieurs sessions d'aide à
l'immigration
lors de notre passage sur la trentaine
de personnes présentes un tiers nous a
confié vouloir aller au Canada le plus
vite possible en arrivant ici il raconte
leur parcours souvent long et parsemé
d’horreur
de viol
j'ai rencontré une jeune fille qui m'a
raconté de comment la violet à mettre
reprise le forêt de dahlia en face de
son mari et ses enfants
[Musique]
la jungle du Daria c'est ce territoire
entre le Panama et la Colombie les
migrants haïtiens arrivent ici après
avoir traversé l'Amérique du Sud où l'on
retrouve les seuls pays qui leur
demandent pas de visa pour s'y rendre
il traverse cette forêt à pied à côté
des animaux des serpents et des
criminels
sont en famille ici et combien d'argent
vous avez sur toi les gens qui n'a pas
d'argent
subitement des viols Emmanuel et sa
famille ont fait ce qu'on appelle dans
le jargon des migrants la route de mots
simples pour définir un péril trajet
devenu très populaire pour arriver ici
au Canada c'est au moins plus de 11 pays
ou 12 nous avons beaucoup de difficultés
dans la route et nous avons rencontré
plusieurs gens là qui
qui est moi aussi dans la route il
n'était pas seul l'an passé plus de 100
000 migrants ont eux aussi traversé les
dangers de l'Amérique centrale mon
groupe était à 27 personnes mais il y a
d'autres groupes il y a des Africains
aussi des Colombiens de cubaines tout ça
nous sommes beaucoup
à l'instar de beaucoup de migrants qui
font cette route le but d'Emmanuel a
toujours été le même
objectif c'est arriver au Canada parce
que c'est un bon pays pour pour les
immigrants
pour ces migrants le dernier obstacle
avant d'arriver au Canada c'est d'entrer
aux Etats-Unis et le père reginaald est
toujours là pour les aider
il est allé à la rencontre Texas il y a
quelques mois lorsqu'un événement
dramatique a marqué les esprits
[Musique]
septembre 2021 des agents américains
repoussent des migrants qui traversent
le Rio Grande et le fleuve qui sépare le
Mexique des États-Unis
ces images ont fait le tour du monde
of the
ils ont été fouettés alors ce que je
vois dans les médias me heurte parce que
aussi sur ma famille
ici à la petite Haïti cette histoire est
toujours
omniprésente
des mois plus tard on sent encore la
douleur et la colère de la communauté
haïtienne
[Musique]
le père Regina dans garde un souvenir un
périssable
tu peux pas été sacrifié à ce que c'est
le la chose la plus horrible que vous
avez vu de votre carrière de votre vie
définitive
à ses yeux les drames ont vécu toutes
ces familles c'est la preuve qu'elles
ont besoin d'une nouvelle terre
d'accueil
et quand vous entendez que certains
disques ce sont de faux réfugiés parce
qu'ils passent par des chemins comme
Roxane qui passe pas par la douane qui
font pas le processus
pour apaiser leur conscience au
justifier leur indifférence et comment
tourner le dos à cette personne comme
vous fermez les yeux ce sont des vrais
réfugiés
je les rencontre
il continue à souffrir
le flux migratoire qui part des
États-Unis vers le Canada n'est donc pas
près de s'éteindre la Floride risque
d'être encore une pause avant d'aller
plus loin et le plus loin c'est doux ici
au Canada
mais la Floride n'est en fait qu'une
partie d'une grande carte où toutes les
routes finissent au chemin Roxane ces
routes sont souvent gérées par des
passeurs et des bandits qui gagnent des
milliers de dollars pour permettre aux
migrants de traverser les frontières
au retour des chauffeurs de taxi qui
n'aiment pas nos questions sur leur
tarif jusqu'au chemin Roxane
[Musique]
quand on parle d'entrée régulière on
parle presque toujours du chemin Roxane
mais vous allez voir que bien d'autres
chemins mènent au Canada suffit d'y
mettre le prix
ils sont des milliers de partout dans le
monde en route vers le Canada
mais tous n'ont pas les mêmes moyens
financiers pour arriver à destination
ça nous a coûté 6000 dollars par
personne pour arriver ici et nous sommes
quatre c'était toutes mes économies
Francisco vient d'arriver au Canada il
dit avoir pris un avion jusqu'au Mexique
pour fuir des groupes armés en Colombie
on a tout vendu pour pouvoir payer les
passeurs mexicains
ont dépensé beaucoup plus que lui il a
écouté combien
[Musique]
Francisco n'a aucun doute il a fait
affaire avec un réseau bien organisé
pour moi il s'agit d'une organisation
parce que dès qu'il vous arrivez à
l'aéroport de Mexico les passaires va
vous chercher
et il sait que vous allez au Canada
c'est d'ailleurs ce pasteur qui va lui
donner un dernier contact pour venir
plus facilement au chemin Roxane
d'une Hubert de la ville des basbourg
que vous devez contacter avant d'arriver
pour nous amener à la frontière et il
est venu nous chercher avec une pancarte
avec notre nom des familles
c'est ici au terminus de platsburg que
Francisco Emmanuel et leur famille sont
arrivés tout comme la grande majorité
des migrants
jour et nuit des taxis et des voitures
privées les attendent
ensuite il parcourt une demi-heure de
route pour aller jusqu'à Roxane
officiellement les taxis sont les seuls
à pouvoir transporter une personne à
n'importe quel endroit de la frontière
mais ici une partie des chauffeurs sont
méfiants et les abus ont déjà été
nombreux
qui demande je ne sais pas 200$ quelque
chose comme ça c'est pas juste selon la
mairesse de Champlain certains
chauffeurs de taxis auraient même menacé
des migrants on m'a dit que il y a
certains
conducteurs qui ont dit je vais vous
mettre à côté de la route si vous ne
payez pas
alors dans ces circonstances on en parle
on ne sait pas où on est on paie
en fait la platsburg les migrants sont
devenus une véritable opportunité
commerciale
y a même des minibus scolaires qui ont
été transformés en taxi ils arrivent ici
tous les jours si je les prends pas
d'autres le franc suis le moins cher
ce chauffeur Tchad et le seul à nous
donner une entrevue il a commencé à
transporter des migrants vers Roxane
juste avant la pandémie et il prend soin
visiblement de promouvoir son activité
[Musique]
comme plusieurs chauffeurs il prend des
réservations de migrants même s'ils sont
encore dans leur pays d'origine
il m'appelle me disent j'arrive jeudi à
15h est-ce que tu peux venir me chercher
et vous appelle du Pakistan de la
Turquie de Colombie aussi de partout
pour sauver des messages tous les jours
oui ou des appels presque tous les jours
lui aussi dénonce le comportement de
certains de ses collègues
il y a des chauffeurs qui ont surchargé
et trompé des migrants certains ont
demandé jusqu'à 300 dollars par personne
ces dernières années trois compagnies de
taxi ont été condamnées par la justice
américaine en raison de leur pratique
commerciale
les immigrants parts et il n'est pas
raisonnable que des propriétaires
d'entreprises essaient de profiter de
cette situation pour se remplir les
poches
même si les devenus mondialement connu
le chemin Roxane n'est que l'une des
voies possibles pour entrer au Canada
sans passer par un poste douanier
et tous les migrants n'ont pas à
traverser toute la mairie pour y arriver
je suis né dans un pays du Moyen-Orient
qui est rangé par la guerre et les
conflits
ce jeune homme que l'on va appeler Alex
à un profil bien différent de nombreux
autres demandeurs d'asile alex est
diplômé d'une université de son pays et
sa famille est fortunée il a facilement
pu prendre l'avion jusqu'à New York
grâce à un visa d'étudiant
les Américains ont approuvé mon visa en
regardant ma situation financière mais
pas mes diplôme ni mon expérience
Alex n'a jamais eu l'intention d'étudier
aux États-Unis
mais sa venue au Canada c'est heurté un
problème majeur le chemin Roxane était
fermé en raison de la pandémie
j'ai simplement vers Gogol pour trouver
une route qui m'amène sur le territoire
canadien
vous pouvez tout voir même les points de
contrôle à la frontière les endroits
sécurisés et les propriétés privées
c'est comme ça qu'Alex est entré au
Canada
il a repéré un passage dans l'État de
New York il a pris un taxi puis la
traversée la frontière en marchant avant
d'aller à Montréal
Alex avait une autre possibilité des
amis à lui ont loué une maison aux
États-Unis à côté de la frontière
canadienne au bord d'un lac
le propriétaire leur a loué la maison à
sachant très bien qu'ils allaient
traverser la frontière il a juste
demandé de tout payer à l'avance en
argent liquide
Alex et ses amis n'avaient aucun
problème d'argent et ils avaient un visa
qui leur permettait de rester vivre aux
États-Unis mais personne ne le
souhaitait
la plupart des gens viennent au Canada
car le gouvernement traite bien les
réfugiés alors que les États-Unis s'en
foutent
l'exemple d'Alex et ses amis illustre
une problématique qui nous a été décrite
par plusieurs sources
grâce à la popularité de Roxane
plusieurs utiliseraient maintenant ce
passage ou des chemins similaires pour
arriver rapidement au Canada au lieu de
faire une demande d'immigration
au retour l'improbable histoire d'un
aubergiste passeur de migrants condamné
par la justice canadienne
nous sommes au chemin Roxane de l'Ouest
aussi connu sous le nom de SMAG le zen
[Musique]
allons maintenant dans l'ouest du pays
où là aussi il y a de nombreux chemins
plus ou moins clandestins entre le
Canada les États-Unis notre équipe a
découvert une auberge où les clients
avaient l'étrange habitude de
disparaître en pleine nuit
[Musique]
la frontière Canada américaine est la
plus longue du monde elle est difficile
à contrôler et les failles potentielles
sont multiples
partout au pays il y a des champs des
routes ou même des maisons qui
permettent facilement de traverser la
frontière parfois ces passages sont
utilisés par des trafiquants de drogue
et d'armes
c'est pas le genre d'histoire qu'on voit
souvent on parle souvent des armes là il
y a un jeune short broc croix qui s'est
fait arrêter en montée régie près de la
frontière américaine les policiers ont
trouvé dans sa voiture près de 250 armes
ces endroits sont aussi utilisés par des
passeurs de migrants mais les
condamnations elles sont plutôt rares
l'une des plus récentes n'est pas liée
au smoroxam elle a eu lieu à l'autre
bout du pays
un Américain soupçonné de faire entrer
illégalement des migrants au Canada via
son gîte à la frontière fait face à 21
chefs d'accusation
l'histoire est rocambolesque elle vit
cette maison de campagne du village
américain de Blaye dont la cour arrière
n'est séparée du Canada que par quelques
pierres
a eu des petits problèmes le monsieur en
question a passé des mois sinon des
années de Monaco richard kerland est un
avocat en immigration devant couvert il
connaît parfaitement cette histoire ce
pays a un petit commerce de famille
vieux monsieur à littéralement serré les
mains des revendicateurs Robert boulet
et le propriétaire du smugglers in
depuis plus de 20 ans
nous sommes au chemin Roxane de l'Ouest
aussi connu sous le nom de smogène
en français signifie contrebandier ou
passeur un nom dont on se vante le
propriétaire des lieux même sur sa
voiture
en décembre la Cour suprême de la
Colombie-Britannique a condamné Robert
Boulay à un mois de prison et à 30 mois
de probation
[Musique]
il appelait des coupables pour avoir été
cette personne originaire d'Afghanistan
et de Syrie à venir au Canada entre 2018
et 2019 à plusieurs reprises il les
cherchait à l'aéroport puis leur donner
des indications pour traverser la
frontière durant la journée ou la nuit
les clients payaient pour plusieurs
nuits et le lendemain matin il n'était
plus là
Greg Boost est à la fois l'avocat et la
mie de Robert boulet qui n'a pas voulu
nous parler en raison de ses ennuis
judiciaires
entrer au Canada Robert Boulay était
aussi un informateur pour des agents
fédéraux américains il leur a déjà
signalé des trafiquants de drogue et de
stupéfiants venant du Canada
aux yeux de son avocat Robert Boulay ne
serait donc pas un criminel
les gens qui ne l'aiment pas et c'est de
le comparer à un criminel on a besoin de
plus de personnes comme lui
combien de personnes sont passées par le
smugglers in avant de demander l'asile
au Canada
[Musique]
j'en ai aucune idée monsieur boulet n'a
pas gardé de traces
mais il n'est pas un coyote c'est un
héros
cette histoire nous montre bien comment
cette frontière est poreuse alors
pourquoi les demandeurs d'asile ne
viennent-ils pas massivement jusqu'ici à
l'ouest du pays cette trop cher vive
avant couvert les climat adorable mais
ils peuvent pas rester les appartements
sont très chers
plus facile d'accès plus abordable
sécuritaire le Québec et le chemin
Roxane sont donc devenus les
destinations privilégiées des demandeurs
d'asile
on vit d'ailleurs une année record en
une seule journée il peut y avoir plus
de 200 personnes à Roxane
taxi camionnette blanche voiture privée
tous les moyens sont bons pour arriver
jusqu'ici sans qu'aucun policier
américain ne s'interpose
les Américains font nada 0 j'admire le
loger pourquoi aller les ressources
nécessaires pour empêcher le flot vers
le Canada parce que l'objectif de leur
système c'est d'expulser ici ces gens
sont aveugles de façon volontaire
dans une réponse officielle l'agence
américaine responsable de la frontière
assure pourtant agir en collaboration
avec le Canada nous travaillons avec la
GRC pour empêcher autant que possible et
passage frontaliers illégaux et nous
continuerons de déjouer les plantes de
ce tentant d'entrer illégalement dans
l'un ou l'autre pays ces passeurs sont
en train
d'exporter des personnes non désirables
de territoire américain vers le Canada
ça veut dire que les passeurs sont en
train de faire le boulot des autorités
immigrations américains alors pourquoi
les américains veulent arrêter ce
système là
sans l'aide des Américains il est
difficile pour le Canada d'agir contre
les réseaux de passeurs
Ottawa aurait aussi besoin de Washington
pour revoir une entente qu'ils ont signé
il y a près de 20 ans et qui empêchent
actuellement les demandeurs d'asile de
se présenter un poste douanier toute
personne qui arrive aux États-Unis doit
faire sa demande d'asile aux États-Unis
ainsi quelqu'un se présente un poste
officiel par exemple la colle il va se
faire retourner aux États-Unis et ne
pourra plus jamais présenter une demande
d'asile au Canada ce que décrit l'avocat
de Stéphanie Valois c'est l'entente sur
les tiers pays sur
parce que c'est pour contourner cet
accord que les migrants se présentent au
chemin Roxane dire que les passages
irréguliers comme Roxane ne sont pas
encadrés à l'heure actuelle par
l'entente souhaites
les gens peuvent se présenter sur le
territoire canadien et une fois sur le
territoire canadien on sait qu'on les
arrête mais par la suite ils ont le
droit de présenter leur demande d'asile
Stéphanie fait partie d'un groupe qui
plaide pour l'abolition de l'Entente ou
les tiers pays sûr devant les tribunaux
pour moi c'est à dire que les demandeurs
pourraient faire leur demande d'asile à
tous tous les postes frontaliers donc
évidemment partout au Canada ça
éviterait le chemin Roxane ça éviterait
toutes les procédures administratives
qu'on voit maintenant
l'avenir de cet accord est par extension
celui du chemin Roxane va se jouer
devant la Cour suprême du Canada le
recours auquel participe Stéphanie
Valois et maintenant rendu devant le
plus haut tribunal du pays
en attendant l'accueil de ces deux
moteurs d'asile à Roxane engendre des
coûts et Monopoly des ressources
importantes que ce soit pour des
infrastructures ou des hôtels pour
héberger les migrants
pour en finir avec ses frais plusieurs
prônes la fermeture du chemin Roxane ce
passage est d'ailleurs devenu un enjeu
politique au Québec on demande
clairement au gouvernement fédéral
aujourd'hui Justin Trudeau de fermer le
chemin Roxane une bonne partie de ces
personnes là sont pas vraiment des
réfugiés si on fermait le chemin Roxane
les gens passeraient ailleurs
[Musique]
on a une frontière énorme qu'on va pas
commencer à armer ou mettre des clôtures
dessus des experts doutent eux aussi de
l'impact d'une fermeture de Roxane si
les règles actuelles restent en place
ça va être un autre chemin ils sont pas
des idiots qu'est-ce que vous préférez
dépenser des dizaines de millions de
dollars pour surveiller
identifier les endroits où les passeurs
vont passer les revenus locataires ou ne
pas dépenser des millions de dollars
créer un endroit centralisé pour gérer
le flot
en termes de scène c'est très logique et
acceptable les personnes traversent la
frontière tout de suite on les identifie
on prend leurs empreintes digitales on
saisit leur passeport on leur fait
passer l'examen médical c'est beaucoup
plus sécuritaire pour les autorités
canadiennes puis les demandeurs d'asile
aussi
le gouvernement de Justin Trudeau a
refusé nos demandes d'entrevue
mais selon nos informations le Canada
tente de convaincre les Américains de
revoir l'entendre tous les tiers pays
sur pour mieux encadrer l'arrivée des
demandeurs d'asile à sa frontière mais
ce serait les Américains qui
traîneraient les pieds
en attendant le chemin Roxane est parti
pour durer et ce ne sont ni les passeurs
ni tous ceux qui en font un commerce qui
demanderont le contraire
[Musique]
l'entente des tiers pays sûrs
suprême d'ailleurs des sources près du
dossier nous disent que la décision
pourrait venir avant la fin de cette
année
[Musique]
c'est tout pour ce premier épisode de la
nouvelle saison d'enquête au nom de
toute l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir
été là la semaine prochaine
exceptionnellement au 7 l'antenne au
débat des chefs je vous donne donc
rendez-vous dans deux semaines pour une
autre enquête
[Musique]